من وين ابدا كلامنا بسؤال
يا ترى مين اكثر ان احنا نحطه في كوبايه
العصير بتاعتها الثلج الطبيعي المستخرج من
سطح البحيره متجمده في الشتاء ولا تنكس
صناعي اللي جاي من الثلاجه عملها الانسان
الغريب ان فترات الناس كانت مؤمنا ان
الفاكهه اللي جايه من مصنع هي الامان وهي
صحيه اكثر بصراحه يعني زمان ما كانش في
الطب بتاع دلوقتي ما كانش فيه فرصه ان هم
يعرفوا الابراج اللي ممكن تحصل او هم
فقدوا ايه لفاكهه جايه من المصنع بلاش دي
مين صحي اكثر السكر الابيض الصناعي اللي
احنا بنحطه في الشاي ولا السكر الطبيعي
المستخرج من نبات طبيعي
اول واحده كده
احنا كبشر عندنا خوف غير مبرر من اي حاجه
كيميائيه اي حاجه الصناعيه اي حاجه كتبته
ان هي مش من صنع الطبيعه دائما
موجود في علم نفسه شركات التسويق بتلعب
اللعبه دي بشكل ما اقولكمش عليه كل حاجه
تجيبها لك تقول لك العصير الطبيعي الفاكهه
الطبيعيه العصير ده طبيعي يا جماعه ده فيه
6%
خلينا نسال سؤال
هو يعني ايه صح علميا او ادق يعني علميا
ممكن نشرح العلم بطريقه معقده هو البحث
والاستقصاء والتجربه ولكن
هو عارف واقف قصاده الطريق
العالم مشي في الطريق
هو اسمه الوسيله العلميه او مجموعه
الخطوات والتجارب اللي العالم بيعملها
عشان يوصل لنتيجه
عشان تكون صح لازم ان اي حد غير العالم
يعمل نفس الخطوات ونفس التجارب يوصل لنفس
النتيجه هل ده دائما بيحصل اكيد لا في
جانب حلو
بيبقى ماشي كويس ومحترم ولذيذ بس يجي في
اخر حته
بسيطه بس دي كويس مفيش مشكله زي لما
الناس كلها كانت مؤمنه ان الارض هي مركز
الكون الجاي
مش مركز
الكون ليه بس
طلع بعديجه ليلي وقال لهم بقى يا جماعه
الشمس كمان مش مركز الكون ما فيش حاجه
اصلا اسمها مركز الكون ده غلط حلو غلط
محمود احنا بطبيعتنا كبشر بنحب نصلح لبعض
اي حاجه ودي حاجه كويسه
بس مش كويس ان العالم يبدا من نقطه هو
عارفها عشان يوصل لنقطه هو عارفها
زي
سنه 97 طلع دكتور اسمه
دم المفروض تتبع حميه غذائيه
طب ليه تعالوا نشوف وريني كده الطريق اللي
انت مشيت عليه هنكتشف ان هو في بدايه
البحث بتاعه كان عايز يثبت بس وجهه نظر
وطلع بعدها ثلاث ابحاث كبار يكتبوا كلام
ان هو قال وعلى فكره الكتاب بتاعه مش
اثنين اللي اشتروه ده ستيف هارفي
رئيس الولايات المتحده
الحمد لله
يعرف سبب انتشار ازمات القلب
دهون
ده انا جدي وجدتك بياكلوا ثابت البلد
ما كانش في الكلام ده طب معلش ثانيه واحده
وريني الطريق اللي انت مشيت عليه ماشي طيب
بما انك بتتكلم عن الشعب الامريكي في
الفتره الاخيره ايه اكثر منتج ذات
استخدامه في الفتره الاخيره السكر
ده حقيقي
انا اقدر اؤكد لكم جميعا تقدر توقفوا قدام
اي حد على وجه البسيطه وتقولوا له يا سيدي
القاضي ان الزبده والدهون بريئه براءه
الذئب من باب يعقوب
اثنين علماء قرروا ان هم يعالجوا السرطان
باستخدام الغضاريف الغضاريف دي ايه الجزء
الموجود في ودن او الجزء الطاهر ده اسمه
غضروف اشمعنى الغضاريف بسيطه قال لك ان
الخناث السرطانيه عشان تكبر بتصنع لنفسها
اوعيه دمويه عشان تقدر تجيب منها الاكل
خلاص سرطانيه من الارانب
دكتور اسمه روبرت لانجر
غضاريف القروش قال لك ان الهيكل العظمي
بتاع القرش كله غضاريف
مش دي مشكله
بعدين واحد اسمه روبرت لي
وعملت كده قال ان اقراص تصنع من غضاريف
القروش تؤخذ عن طريق الفم تقدر تعالج
السرطان
الاول
طب ما ترد علي يا جدعان رد عليه طلع اربع
ابحاث بيتكلموا عن ازاي هو كان غلط يا
راجل ده اتعامل بحث بيتكلم عن احصائيه
لانواع السرطان اللي بتصيب الحيوانات 12
قرش كان عندهم سرطان ده فيه حوالي اربع
قروش فيهم كان عندهم سرطان في الغضاريف
من كل القصص اللي فاتت دي والتجاره
زي المجتمع القروش انتم متخيلين المجاز
اللي كانت بتحصل عشان يستخرجه بس غضاريف
القروش عشان يعالجوا بها علاج وهم من
الناس
او قد ايه السكر ما زال بيتباع لحد
النهارده
ولكن التجربه اللي جايه هي حاجه اثرت على
الناس في وقتها
وما زالت بتاثر وهتفضل تاثر لحد عمر
الراجل ده كان شغال على مشروع القنبله
النوويه في مشروع الهاتف بعد ما خلصت
طب ازاي بسيطه قال لك ان العناصر المشعه
خالص ما بتحاولش مثلا مع الوقت بيتحول
للرصاص طيب هيقيس ازاي برده بسيطه
50% من الشويه اللي في ايدي بعد اربعه
ونصف مليون سنه هيتحولوا الرصاصي خالص انا
هاقيس كميه اليورانيوم في صخور الارض
وكميه الرصاص في صخور الارض واشوف النسبه
وصلت لحد فين احنا في انهي ليفل وعلى
وصلنا يعرف عمر
العربي
صوتها عالي
ومش دي بس المشكله المحرك بتاع العربيه دي
كان قوي لدرجه انه الوقود اللي كان موجود
في الوقت ده كان اضعف من انه يستحمل شغل
الوقود القوي فكان صوتها عالي نتيجه لظهر
المحرك كان بيحرق الوقود قبل ميعاده فيحصل
فرقعات زياده عن اللزوم سموها
تاثير الخط فكان لازم له وقود جديد يتصرف
مع النوقف ده فجاب الراجل ده
توماس الراجل ده
قعد خمس سنين
اختي مالكوا في ايه
بسيطه هو فعلا انت المفروض كويس
ريحته مش وحشه خالص تستخدم وفعلا طلع وقود
جديد اسمه
فعلا طلعت محركات بعد كده كثير العربيات
كلها بدات تستخدم نفس الوقود بس بمحركات
اقوى والمصانع التثبيني والناس تشتغل
يحصل مشكله في الدرس كده من الموظفين
اللي حصل جاء لهم تسمم رصاص
اه اصل احنا نسينا لقطه معينه فاكرين لما
عمل الوقود اول مره طبعا كان الجهاز فقال
له ما تتفضل معنا تقول لنا كده في محاضره
ازاي عملت الانجاز الجميل ده
مشكله الرصاص انه يتخزن في العظم انت مش
بيخرج من الجسم بسهوله وبيعمل حاجه اسمها
الاعصاب بتاعتنا بتبقى مغلفه كده بطبقه
دهنيه دي بتسرع الرسائل العصبيه الرصاص
بيشيل الطبقه الدهنيه
توماس لما الطلب منه يطلع في اول محاضره
ما طلعش عشان كان في فلوريدا بس ما كانش
بياجز كان بيتعالج من تسمم الرصاص
لما انتشر الخبر بتاع الموظفين اللي جالهم
مشكله طلع على الملا وقال لهم ما تخافوش
لو كنت كويس بصوا راح ادلقوا على ايده
وقعد يشم فيه لمده دقيقه كامله الناس صدقت
مين اللي مصدقش
كلير لما كان شغال في رساله البحث بتاعته
لها حاجه غريبه كل ما يجيب عينه يورانيوم
نقيس نسبه اليورانيوم فيها يلاقيهم تقريبا
في كل العينات قريبين من بعض وده حاجه
مهمه ولازم يقيس اكتر من مره الارض
بس كل ما يجي يقيس الرصاص يلاقي مشكله
يقعد يروح الاوضه وينظف ويمسح ويجيب
شرشوبه وست الشبابيك ما فيش فائده لدرجه
ان هو في اوضه دلوقتي اللي هي اعظم اوضه
على وجه الارض هو اللي عملها عشان بس يقيس
نسبه الرصاص بس في رصاص جاي من بره جاي
منين
اخذ
الجثث الناس المتوفيه حديثه وتوقع انه
هيلاقي مثلا
كلير دخل في المنافسه ضد توماس على ان
الوقود ده عامل كوارث
وكان الرصاص من الوقود بقرار دولي الى
يومنا هذا شغال منع اضافه الرصاص لاي وقود
المشكله ان احنا فتره من عمر الارض تعرضنا
للرصاص صح طيب ايه لازمته دلوقتي لا ما هو
لسه موجود طيب اكيد مش مناسب زي زمان اه
اكيد بس يعني في دراسه طلعت بتقول ان
الاطفال اللي تعرضوا للنسب اقل من النسب
المسموح بها الرصاص كان عندهم مشاكل ذهنيه
ومشاكل الذاكره ونقص معدلات الزكاه ومشاكل
سلوكيه زي العنف بل ان الاطفال اللي
تعرضوا النسب اعلى كانت معدلات تفوقهم
الدراسيه في الثانويه والجامعه سيئه جدا
دراسه ثالثه قالت ان الرصاص ممكن يكون
مسؤول عن تنتين من حجم الاعاقات الذهنيه
الغير مفسره
الدراسه رابعه قالت ان الرصاص ممكن يكون
مسؤول عن ضياع اكثر من 800 مليون نقطه في
اختبارات الذكاء كان ممكن
يتغير عبر العصور
بس صح صح
الصح ممكن يبقى في اصح منك
صاحب علينا كثير الصحه علمنا
السمكه ذاكرتها اكثر من ثلاث ثواني بتقعد
لحد ثلاث شهور
الصحه علينا اللي احنا بنستخدم اكثر من
10% من القدره
مش بيكره اللون الاحمر ولا حاجه غلط
لابس نظاره بيدعي انه بيتكلم عن الصح يبقى
صح
صور
فكر بص بص على المصادر بس اهم من كل ده
بعد ما تعرف الصح
تعمل الصح
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]